my question for you do you feel like I
was incorrect do you think a woman
should be able to gain all the weight
she wants I don't think women they think
I'm like oh my God I'm gonna eat so much
today because I want to become so fat
but at some point nobody does think that
don't let themselves go when you get
there yeah like at some point there's a
point where it becomes a choice like I'm
not saying yeah definitely that's not
like your body's gonna my mom had seven
kids she doesn't look the same as she
did when she was 22. but the thing is
she's always tried to stay in shape the
best she could and look good for my dad
so my whole point is like it wasn't
about the whale like the point the point
is that like like men deserve to have
standards